for the first time in nearly half a
century nasa has built a rocket that can
send astronauts back to the moon the
space launch system artemis the rocket
is longer than a football field more
powerful than the famous saturn v from
the apollo program which last flew in
1973 nasa is preparing its first new
moon rocket for a first test launch in
the coming months mark straussman got an
up-close look and shows us nasa's plan
for a timeline on the lunar landing
both iconic and daunting nasa's vehicle
assembly building is one of the largest
in the world but obviously you need
something this big for for a vehicle
this big towering inside a new rocket
that makes you feel just as puny it's
called the space launch system or sls
this thing is massive it's about 322
feet tall so that's taller than the
statue of liberty we had to step way
back with nasa test director dan flores
to get a good look at the most powerful
rocket ever built if you look past the
scaffolding you can see the nose of the
two boosters yep
how powerful so the boosters provide
about seven million pounds of thrust
that lift off that's a lot of power
a lot of power
nasa spent 11 months stacking this mega
rocket piece by piece
the core stage 212 feet long arrived by
barge its four engines will produce
another 2 million pounds of thrust
you've got a rope up in there cranes
gingerly lifted and lowered billions of
dollars of space hardware into place
and then at the very top
the very top you have orion
orion is the crew capsule flores took us
up 311 feet for a closer look when
you're looking at this close you look at
all the hundreds of thousands of nuts
and bolts that have to be torqued the
hours spent by our technicians getting
this work done to get us to this major
milestone and every one of those bolts
better be perfect
they better be right that's because
early next year this rocket and capsule
will roll to the launch pad for a
critical test flight artemis one
sls will launch orion on a course 40 000
miles beyond the moon and back no
astronauts will be on board this flight
but it's the first in a series of
increasingly complex lunar missions
we've got a moon bound rocket stacked
with a crew capsule for the first time
since
apollo 17 in 1972. oh this is a big deal
and it is beautiful and it is a monster
after more than 30 billion dollars in
development costs nasa administrator
bill nelson knows the pressure is on for
that test flight to go well i am an
optimist by nature true
space flight is risky
and there are penalties that you pay
because
mistakes are made by human beings the
next mission artemis ii will have a crew
it's due to fly around the moon by may
2024
nasa is now hoping artemis iii a moon
landing using spacex's starship happened
sometime in 2025.
that crew will include the first female
moonwalker and astronaut kayla behrens
one of the candidates if they ask who
wants to go to the moon first you're
raising your hand oh yeah i think we all
raised our hands like who would not want
to go to the moon whatever the crew
ends up being we're going to be pumped
for each other but first the most
complex rocket in history has to work
america's lunar future depends on it
for cbs mornings mark strassman at the
kennedy space center
i am so genuinely excited for this era
of space exploration that we are in
when i was a kid we had
a lot of kids um that i knew had posters
of buzz aldrin of course michael collins
on their wall we knew all the astronauts
we knew all the different apollo
missions we followed them um this is
really cool because of the advancements
in technology it just seems like we have
so much at the palm of our hands yes
don't you just love science
25 jamie three of us
let's let's volunteer let's do it okay
jamie
you're coming okay we're just gonna take
you along with us okay